all right so the Transformers are
rolling out in 90s fashion for Rise of
the Beast and uh yeah this guy grew up
watching The Animated Beast Wars series
so I had High Hopes going into this
reboot I don't know if it's actually a
reboot of the Transformers so in this
video we're going to be breaking down
this latest machine on machine
transforming Fest explaining the ending
how it sets up something huge something
huge in the universe some small
callbacks to the original series along
with our thoughts of the film spoilers
are coming so if you haven't had a
chance to check it out then I highly
recommend you transform and drive out of
here now but please do hit that like
button and make sure to subscribe for
breakdowns like this every day with all
of that out of the way thank you so much
for clicking this again I am Jared now
let's get into rise of the beasts
oh
[Music]
all right so rise the Beast kicks off
introducing Unicron the planet devouring
dark God in the distant future trying to
destroy the max small Homeworld sending
the evil Scourge his trusted General
down to retrieve the transwarp key
technology so he's able to jump from
Universe to Universe feasting on
anything and everything
eternally uh a lot a lot of Fairly heady
stuff just to set this movie up
especially if you don't have much
knowledge on the Transformers or beast
wars lore so so stick with me here ape
link the leader of the maximos who looks
like a much more metallic version of
Optimus Prime promotes Primal as the new
leader of the maximals as he stays back
to fight off Scourge giving them enough
time to safely escape with the transwarp
key the maximos are successfully
transported to what is supposed to be
prehistoric Earth via the ark if uh if
we're going off the Animated Beast Wars
lore ape link perishes at the hands of
scourge ripping off his Insignia and
fusing it to his body Flash Forward now
as it's 1994 hip hop and Brooklyn Vibes
are flowing people as we're introduced
to the human counterparts of this movie
first is Noah in ex-military electronics
expert struggling to find a job to help
support his family and brother who is
unfortunately suffering from a Sickle
Cell disorder however unsuccessful
turning to other means of cash flow
something uh borderline illegal second
is Elena as an overlooked intern at the
Ellis Island Museum whose boss
constantly takes credit for her
discoveries she is no doubt 100 the
expositional mouthpiece of this movie
like like I kind of feel bad for
Fishback anyway it's a dual type story
happening right now as Noah attempts to
steal a fancy pants souped-up car only
to realize that it's Mirage take him on
an uncontrolled police chase the two
then become fast friends here to meet up
with the other Autobots hiding on Earth
because the trans warp key has now been
activated and they want to go home this
is because Elena stayed late at the
Museum running tests on the new artifact
that came in crumbling it only to reveal
that the key was hiding inside of it
however this also alerts the likes of
scourge and his tarot con buddies of
night bird and battle trap so it's an
all-out explosive rush for the key as
the autobots and Scourge crew get into
fisticuffs resulting in Bumblebee's
spark being extinguished and Scourge
escaping with the key however air razor
who showed up in the last bit of the
fight fills them all in that the key
that Scourge got was only actually half
of the key the other half is hidden in
Peru with the other maximals having
control of it it's a big adventure full
of mumbo jumbo as they arrive to Peru
meet up with the other maximos who claim
they are warriors of the Autobots past
and future and this is because they use
the transwarp key to travel back into
the past as Scourge descends upon them
tracking air razor who had been affected
by scourge's dark energy from an earlier
battle Primal makes the tough decision
here to end air Razor Spark because of
the infection while Noah is about to
destroy the other half of the maximos
transwarp key saving Earth from Unicron
but would then strand the Autobots on
Earth Optimus pleads with him man I'll
do anything finally seeing how the
humans and Autobots can work together
resulting in Noah standing down but
Scourge swoops in and collects the other
half of the key Scourge now has both
halves of the key combines the two
making what looks like a tower straight
out of Lord of the Rings The Two Towers
appear lava and all as all is set in
motion for Unicron to now take the juicy
big old juicy bite out of Earth opening
a giant portal in the sky loads of
Terracon drones flow from the tower as
the maximals and Autobots agree to fight
as a distraction to allow Noah and Elena
to sneak through underground tunnels
entering a special access code to
deactivate the portal console Scourge
obviously catches on to their plan but
Mirage swoops in to help distract him
while Noah and Elena are doing their
thing Mirage is bested by Scourge but in
his last few moments tells Noah to take
over the wheel transforming into an
exosuit for Noah to use this is straight
out of the original Transformers cartoon
series but looks a lot more like Mega
Man X's suit once he gets all of the
zero upgrades uh in that game Optimus
Prime and Noah pulled double time facing
off with Scourge while a giant energy
Blast from the trans warp Tower brings
Unicron even closer it also activates
all of the raw Energon in the ground
boosting bumblebee spark back to life
probably what is the best scene of the
movie is Bumblebee skydiving back into
the action while LL Cool J's Mama Said
Knock You Out plays like um
chef's kiss right here B's return helps
with the other maximals and Autobots on
the battlefield and gives Prime enough
juice to get the advantage on Scourge
cutting off his arm ripping out his
spine like a damn Mortal Kombat Fatality
and reclaiming Bumblebee's Autobot
emblem of which was ripped from B upon
dying earlier in a last ditch effort
Prime chooses to sacrifice himself to
destroy the transwarp key thus stranding
them on Earth after doing so there is a
giant vacuum like sucking from the
Unicron portal as Prime tries to use his
ax to Anchor himself to the ground
however the sucking is like Lana rhode's
strength as primes ax slips right as
it's about to give away Noah swoops in
holding Prime as then Primal joins in
and holds them rescuing them from the
blast radius of the exploded transwarp
key they regroup with both Prime and
Primal given speeches about how Unicron
is still out there we'll do anything to
get back to Earth and to let him come it
looks like the two factions are now
homies straight up doing their thing as
the Autobots return back to New York
City and Noah looking at the Mirage exo
suit that helped save his life the film
closes with Noah returning back home to
New York continuing his job search to
support his family as he sits down with
Michael Kelly's character in some weird
Warehouse interviewing for what is
supposed to be a simple security guard
job Kelly mentions that Noah's resume is
uh honestly pretty lackluster when Noah
goes off on a run of explaining how he
recently saved the world with the
autobots and maximals blah blah blah but
not outing them like a child telling
stories in order to get the gig Kelly
reveals he knows all about his recent
exploits sliding him a business card
saying he wants Noah for his team he
wants him to work for him unsure of
what's really going on Kelly stands up
from his desk touching the shield-shaped
plaque hanging behind him causing the
wall to move to reveal a massive
military facility as the two step onto
an elevator type platform to descend
there is a futuristic looking jet being
built in the background Noah like us
viewers is hella confused turning over
the card to reveal a falcon-like logo
with a star with the words GI Joe that's
right baby the Transformers are getting
in bed with the Joes up sandwiches oh
[__] get the [__] out of here what are
you doing go [__] that's [__] out of
here you stupid idiot so it looks like
this is going to be the start of the
fabled has bro verse so get ready to get
some souped-up muscle cars and lots of
baby oiled Bros with cut off sleeves
this this actually this actually makes
sense I'm surprised it wasn't done
before with all of the Cinematic
universes running amok out there but
with Hasbro owning the rights to both of
these properties it feels right and safe
to have them kind of feed off of one
another especially with the rumor of a
GI Joe reboot currently in the works
because uh yeah 2021 Snake Eyes was not
it producer Lorenzo day bonaventura even
dropped a few nuggets in recent
interviews alluding to this crossover
it's even came aboard and was
immediately pushing in that direction
and thankfully the movie really sort of
led us to a nice way to bring it
together for sure it's going to play a
part in the next movie it's it's too
good and I the audience reaction has
been really gratifying to that very
small but very cool little beat
surprisingly this won't be the first
time these franchises match up with the
first crossover actually being featured
in a handful of issues in the 1986
Marvel Comics run titled GI Joe and the
Transformers here the factions teamed up
fighting over control of a mobile power
station and hilariously saw the Joe's
accidentally blowing the [__] out of
Bumblebee this followed by a handful of
other team up and versus comic runs and
even jumped over to animation with some
of the Joe's cameoing in the third
season of the original Transformers
cartoon so the pair have history with
one another and it feels like Mirage and
Noah are going to be the initial
connective tissue between these two
franchises probably leading to a full
out you know Autobots and Joe's versus
Cobra and decepticon Saturday morning
cartoon battle royale there was already
a massive military presence since in the
previous Transformers film so slap on a
new name on them boom bam done they are
now the Joes
oh and there is a small mid-credit scene
that shows Noah tinkering around with
what looks to be an old junkyard vehicle
kind of pieced together piecemeal and
whatnot as he puts in some finishing
touches and the car transforms back into
Mirage his old buddy is back in the end
of the movie we were led to believe that
Mirage perished at the hands of scourge
but the exo suit technology that Noah
used in the final battle must have still
had a bit of mirage's spark and Essence
still in it allowing him to be implanted
into this new skeleton of a car so it
looks like this duo will continue on
with the franchise similar to you know
Sam and Bumblebee or Charlie and
Bumblebee if that is if that is that
they get an actual green light for the
sequel from this Beast War Story which
is uh yeah honestly it's probably gonna
happen especially with this GI Joe
tie-in I think rise of the beasts is
fine enjoyable at times really
separating itself from the overall tone
of the Bay films by infusing everything
with a 90s hip-hop soundtrack as a weird
kid who binged way too much of the Beast
Wars animated series and had multiple of
their action figures I was beyond
ecstatic to see these big old beasts
doing their transforming Shenanigans The
Mirage and Noah team up is something
that could blossom into something really
cool like B and Sam especially with the
setup at the end of this movie and I
liked what kappel Jr had prime be you
know more of this jaded character
growing towards that Autobot leader we
know and love unfortunately I I'm gonna
give this movie a 6 out of 10 because
although there were several moments and
jokes that really hit this movie is
stuffed and I mean stuffed with
Exposition fishback's character is
basically a talking head of information
the audience needs to know while it
bleeds over into other characters too
plus with them finally only bringing the
maximals into the picture it's honestly
kinda lackluster they unfortunately have
to share the spotlight and it's probably
because they were scared that like
casual audiences wouldn't understand on
top of that I personally think that they
dropped the ball by not including any
actual Decepticons or Predacons like
waspinator where's my boy you did em
dirty The Story Goes Through the the
Motions the emotional beats not hitting
at all so in the end does it really
matter but the Joes and Transformers
teaming up could be something badass
some cautiously optimistic on that front
anyway let us know your thoughts on
Transformers rise of the beast in the
comments was this a much warranted
reboot bringing in the Obscure Beast
Wars lore or did this actually make you
miss the over-the-top explosive bayham
of the first few Michael Bay
Transformers movies again let us know in
the comments below anyway if you want to
support the channel for as little as 99
cents a month then please click that
join button below and as a thank you
you'll get exclusive Early Access to
videos every single week you're a super
special group also just a heads up this
will be one of my very last videos here
at heavy spoilers a big thank you to the
crew here for bringing me on board and
everyone who has been willing to give me
a chance Paul and the editors Matt and
Stich thank you it was a tough decision
but personal and health reasons had
other plans I'll still be around making
my own personal stuff on my Social
account sporadically making content here
or there so if you want to follow me on
Tick Tock Instagram YouTube Facebook all
of the socials search Jared buckendall
jbox Studios or J Buck movies and you'll
be sure to find me there again thank you
to everyone for everything my final
video will be a breakdown of 1997's the
game so be sure to stay tuned for that
again I've been your host Jared and
you've all been great I'll see you in
the next one take care and